if you were stuck in horrifying
Financial ruin what would you do the
only way to escape crippling debt is to
risk your life playing Twisted games
with brutal punishments I'm here to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the Dead games
in Tomodachi game this honest kid is
about to find out that hard work doesn't
pay off yuichi here Works tirelessly for
a delivery company and other part-time
jobs to pay for his school trip and he
finally makes enough cash to go on his
dream trip however he's going to soon
realize that it was all for nothing the
next day the principal announces that 2
million yen that they all collected for
their school trip has been stolen
black-haired girl she-ho begs for
forgiveness for losing the money telling
the class that someone had taken it from
her locker that night yuichi receives a
letter from chiho telling him to meet
her outside of school as soon as
possible that's when he arrives at the
entrance seeing all of his friends
waiting for him to fess up and tell them
why AI he sent them all the same creepy
letter asking them to meet up with him
the group realizes that someone else not
yuichi sent them all the same letter
suddenly the group is attacked and they
black out they wake up in a clear white
room only to be greeted by this creepy
looking mascot manaboo he tells the
group that they've been entered into a
series of games each game giving them 2
million yen if they win however there's
a catch one of them has 20 million yen
in debt that must be paid off this
glasses guy tenji approaches the mascot
and accuses him of illegally kidnapping
them but manabu has a trick up his
sleeve he tells them that someone
already paid for the entry fee of 2
million yen the exact same amount that
was stolen for the school trip however
he gives them the option to quit if they
want to but whoever leaves has to pay
the debt off by themselves bloodline
Heroes of lithis is a visually stunning
free to play mobile game set in a
fantasy world full of Adventure and
deadly enemies find yourself trustworthy
companions completely customizable and
continue your bloodline birth new
Champions who will create new and
Powerful abilities that will suit your
gameplay style my favorite is the
cargook which are big strong and
powerful but what's your favorite
challenge both Ai and players online to
battle the forces of darkness and cement
your bloodline as the strongest in the
world the game is available on both IOS
and Android meaning anyone can join and
go on Epic Adventures like the ones are
how to beat anime heroes have to suffer
through on a weekly basis use my link
and get a half Dragonborn half demigod
hybrid air for free and trust me when I
tell you my good webs these are very
rare and 100
dangerous download and try out the game
now for free and use my linking gift
code in the description to get a special
starter pack that is worth twenty
dollars 100 gold and 100 diamonds use
the promo code BL
dhol2 for all the naughty little goodies
mentioned thank you bloodlight Heroes of
lithis for sponsoring this video and now
back to the show okay this is clearly
one of the most illegal things I have
ever witnessed a group of high school
students have just been blackmailed
kidnapped and told that one of them has
20 million yen in debt now there's a lot
of different ways to handle this
situation and I say becoming violent
seems like the easiest one if I were
these students I would beat the ever
living crap out of manabu here this
serves two purposes one we get revenge
on him or whoever he works for and
potentially beating him down hard enough
that he'll confess who the death belongs
to however in reality that is a terrible
idea what we really need to do is to put
on our Sherlock and figure out who has
the 20 million yen in debt the phrase
whoever smelted dealt it might be a good
idea that we can use to narrow down our
list of suspects and at the top of my
list is black-haired girl and this
glasses guy tenji with his glasses dudes
with glasses are always the mysterious
blokes but this black-haired girl might
just be one of those innocent types that
has a mysterious dark side when [ __ ]
hits the fan and we already know the
deal with this dude this kid's got some
glasses guy energy about him and
according to past animes the dudes with
glasses are usually Bonafide perverts am
I right however I wouldn't try ganging
up on him just yet I would use some
psychological trickery and over time
make them spit their dirty little
secrets right into our ear holes manaboo
introduces them to a fake classroom and
gives them name tags with a number on
the other side each one shows them the
four million death they owe and if they
clear the game they'll be debt free
however they're not allowed to show the
amount of death or speak to other people
during question time if they do the
participant will have their fine doubled
Malibu shows them a demonstration of
what happens when they all give the same
correct answer they must work together
or else one of them will be given a
massive debt to pay the mascot then
gives them their first question is the
tallest mountain in Japan Mount Fuji
suddenly coin moves to no and they fail
the first round the second question is
given as does one plus one equal two and
the coin moves to the wrong side and
they fail once again the third question
is read out by tenji who asks is the
country called Japan in English the
students fail a third time to answer
correctly and yuichi here begins to grow
paranoid that someone is sabotaging the
game on purpose with only two questions
remaining they continue to get the
questions wrong and then the final part
of game one begins the shy girl yutori
is given the final question she asked
the group will we always be friends but
before everybody can put their finger
down on the coin and answer yuichi
speaks out and asks a rather naughty
question and is penalized by having his
debt increased two-fold he tells the
group that the answer is simple just say
yes the students make up their mind and
answer the final question by moving the
coin on to the correct answer the group
has successfully cleared the game and
wins 2 million yen but yuichi here is
trapped and in even more debt than
before after the game yuichi and the
black-haired girl shio have a
conversation about who the traitor is he
accuses her of stealing the money but
she denies having any involvement with
what happened and with this game okay
that was extremely close things could
have gone wrong so quick and somebody in
this group has betrayed us it could be
one of them or all of them the questions
weren't given to test our knowledge they
were given to us to test our friendship
getting into this situation was bad
enough but purposely trying to sabotage
the group's success well that means
somebody here is pretty dangy while we
might not be able to catch the traitor
this time around we should be on the
lookout for telltale signs of a liar in
the next game now things such as eye
twitches and looking away when speaking
shouldn't be used as 100 concrete proof
that someone is lying these aren't the
facts and there's going to be a strong
punishment for whoever the trader is so
we better get it right the first time
the only way to properly determine if
something is a lie is through
inconsistency the two most suspicious
people are shiho and she eBay both of
them announced that the class's money
was missing however that isn't a
Surefire way to narrow down our list of
suspects it is a start though if I was
yuichi I'd be recalling every single
interaction I've ever had with my
classmates from the very start of our
friendship to before the game started we
should be looking out for any moments
where our friends might have backstabbed
us or done something suspicious it might
sound like a stretch right now but with
this we should be able to clue in to a
potential suspect as long as we're sure
of whatever past memory we can conjure
up the students are sent to a roof for
the next game Professor manabu now
introduces game 2 by the name of bad
mouth suguroku each participant must go
into a booth and write a bad mouth
confession about another participant
once the messages have been sent viewers
watching from the sky will rate which
confession is the worst in order from
first to last the ranked confessions
will determine how many spaces they move
down the ladder from one space to five
the first to reach the end will suffer a
massive loss but in doing so we'll give
everyone 400 000 Yen and reward anyone
left on the board will be given an extra
1 million yen in debt but then they have
the option to be able to go home for a
bit and skip the third game if no one
puts down a confession and leaves the
card blank everyone will move down one
space together and if they keep
repeating the process of skipping the
questions they will all be able to clear
the game in one piece with a combined 2
million yen in reward but if they make
that choice then they have to play the
third game okay now that we've
experienced the glories of the first
game we need to prepare for any kind of
weird crap that could happen next if we
really think about it and break down the
game one there seems to be an element of
trust that is recurring throughout now
there's always the possibility that
whoever stole the money is in cahoots
with this money sucking game I'd be
weighing my options out and assessing
what's easier win the game and move on
to a third game or take an increased
amount of debt and be free if I was
yuichi the more attempting option would
be to just take on more debt and lose
the game on purpose there's no reason
stick around and no one can stop us from
leaving this place once and for all heck
winning this game and moving on to the
next looks like it involves jumping off
of a building I don't know about you but
that does not look like a good time to
me other than attacking manabu however
there's only one other option that
doesn't involve playing the game we
could just take a look around and see if
there's any way that we can get back
down this building assuming this
building is in fact actually a building
and not just some set that someone
cooked up for a sick twisted game if the
building is real there's many ways to
safely descend down a build and it
requires more brains than Braun the
chain-linked fence is a perfect starting
point to begin The Descent if this is a
real building they will only have to
climb down a small bit to get down to
the next window and from then we could
try to force our way in and make our way
down to the ground floor and get away
from this game for good the first
confessions are given out and the group
manages to work together as a team
moving only one space suddenly a message
appears above them stating that they've
been penalized one hundred thousand yet
they're shocked and manobu reveals that
a different penalty is attached with
each space and that's when someone puts
down a confession in the next round let
the mind games begin chiho moves down
five spaces while the others stay put in
the next round three confessions are
given out with the black-haired girl
taking the lead once again the next
round is set and a confession is given
out Shire girl yutori is mortified and
is given 100 of the viewer's vote manabu
reminds the group that whoever reaches
the goal first will take on everyone
else's debt the game continues and the
next confession is read and turns out
glasses guy tenji is lying about his age
he admits that the confession is a
little harsh but true and reveals that
only she-ho should know about it since
they were childhood friends the results
are decided with shiho in first tenji in
second as of round six shiho hears in
first place with 18 spaces ahead
trashing the competition that's when she
hosts steps on a special space and is
given a dangerous ability she can pick
anyone in the group to have all of their
secrets
depending on how bad the secret is the
percentage of votes will determine how
many steps they take she decides to
choose shebe and the mascot reveals that
his lawyer father has been doing some
nasty things after hours and has been
spending a lot of money to cover it all
up the votes are then decided and chibe
moves into second place with 17 spaces
however yuichi here has something up his
sleeve he puts down a confession into
the booth that states shibe has killed
someone they take a special vote and 99
of the viewers believe that chibei is a
killer now shibe is at first place with
22 spaces yuichi Comforts him and
assures that his buddy isn't a murderer
he tells the group to stop fighting
amongst each other because there's only
one bad egg in this nest and he knows
exactly who it is however he's not ready
to reveal who it is just yet iuichi
tells them that the game is extremely
suspicious and unfair no matter what
they do they'll be penalized and placed
into even further death he reminds the
group that round six was the first time
they were given a debt reduction and
realizes that there are both negative
and positive spaces the negative spaces
were loaded at the front to make the
group lose trust in each other while the
positive spaces slowly increase in the
second half to reveal that teamwork is
essential okay now we know that we've
been tricked yet again however this is
on us the game is literally called the
friends game everything here happens for
a reason and this is something to keep
in mind if we make it to game three
whoever's controlling this game has
stacked the odds against us and all we
need to do is to think carefully about
our next step now the hardest part of
this game is to trust our teammates the
messages flying above us are there for
the sole purpose of making us turn on
each other if I was yuichi at this point
I'd let the game play out as normal
without any more planning we know that
the distrust within the group is at an
all-time high and there's not much you
can do to influence a bunch of hormonal
teenagers let's be honest but who knows
maybe we can lose the game and ask
shibae's Evil lawyer father to put a few
strings out and let us off the hook with
all of this debt chibe's dad is pretty
sleazy but shebe is our best buddy right
and that means we could blackmail him
with the information we now have of
course it's been broadcasted on live
stream but we don't know who the hell is
watching this [ __ ] or how many viewers
this illegal game even has the next
round monibou suddenly announces that
there were 10 cards in the Box tenji
confronts yuichi and tells him that his
plan was doomed to fail from the start
suddenly he reveals another way to
figure out who the traitor is once and
for all since shiho is going to reach
the end regardless he tells everyone to
write down the same confession I'm the
one who applied to the Tomodachi game if
they all write the same thing the trader
will be the only one who is not going to
be penalized but everyone but the trader
will be moved one space above shiho
allowing everyone but the traitor to
reach the goal the group agrees on this
idea and they're all hand in their
confession papers when the papers are
read out though only one reads the
phrase yuichi mentioned tenji shocked he
breaks down on the spot and uh demands
that this creepy glasses guy finally
reveal if he was the one who applied for
this evil death game the broken man
finally admits that he did it and the
traitor has been uncovered but suddenly
out of the blue manibu interrupts to
tell them all that chiho is still going
to be the only one moving on to game
three but yuichi Whispers to the mascot
that he lied in round seven and broke
the rules suddenly manipu announces that
the game is over and iuichi is penalized
by taking chiho's place and he's about
to leave but tenji gets up and reveals
that he also told a lie and he joins
yuichi in the third game the two wake up
in a cave and are told to stay in there
for three days yuichi finds a single
bottle of water that is supposed to last
them the entire time tenji reveals
something shocking this is his second
time in the Tomodachi game this kid is
20 million yen in debt and chiho is the
reason for all of it okay what did I say
about Creepy glasses got energy but
false crazy Revelations aside this
situation is really really really bad
and we could die before this third game
even Begins the average person can only
survive without water for a few days at
most it wouldn't be so bad if it was
just food as we can survive for way
longer without food but water water is
something we must have regularly and
we've been without water for at least a
day with the kidnapping and two previous
games this situation is life and death
however it's really not that bad if we
do a few simple key things what I would
do if I was them would be to take off
all of my clothes hear me out now I know
it might be a bit awkward for the first
few hours but any extra layers of
clothing will make us sweat more and
cause us to lose precious resources
within our body this also goes hand in
hand with doing absolutely no physical
activity there's not much we can do
inside a cave so making sure we don't
move around too much or accidentally
argue amongst ourselves is the most
important thing to our survival once
that's settled we can focus on
conserving the resources we do have in
order to stay alive and sorta healthy
we've been given a single bottle of
water between the two of us which is not
ideal for staying hydrated the human
body needs at least one and a half
liters of water to stay properly
hydrated assuming this bottle is one and
a half liters from the way it looks we
have about 750 milliliters for each of
us it's not going to be pretty but we
can survive if we conserve our water and
limit our physical activity after three
brutal days the boys leave the cave to
find themselves in front of now Sergeant
monaboo the mascot introduces them to
their enemy team and the final game
friendly hide and seek both groups will
choose one person to hide in the forest
and The Seekers will need to find the
hidden enemy however The Seekers can
switch sides if it looks like they're
about to lose suddenly manibu tells the
smaller group that one other person in
an entirely different team made it also
to game three and if they want they can
have this person join their team yuichi
asks if it's a girl and manabu says yes
and yuichi immediately accepts the offer
that's when this bombshell of a girl
Maria steps out and introduces herself
to the others manipu continues with
explaining the rules telling them that
violence is prohibited against the other
team and The Hider cannot move once they
picked a location surveillance cameras
are all over the forest to make sure
they don't break the rules they've been
given phones that they can use to
contact either side if they want and
there's a big stash of food exposed in
the middle of the forest for anyone
who's brave enough to go and get it if
they're willing to risk getting caught
last but not least the hiders are handed
a give up grenade if they decide to call
it quits and end the game as the loser
okay if I were the boys I'd be using our
new teammate as a complete guinea pig
for our operation friendly hide and seek
is a game of wits and using the person
who's not starving is probably the
better bet at winning the game this is
why this slim young Thang is the perfect
bait she has no option but to take our
advice if she wants to continue playing
anyways while it's not going to sound
pretty we should do our best to convince
her that we're morally sound people just
so we can take advantage of her
abilities when we get the chance buy our
ourselves we should ask manabu his
violence against teammates prohibited
and if it isn't that means we can do
whatever we want to this new recruit if
it were me I would have her appointed as
The Hider and instantly snatch the give
up grenade from her we don't know her we
can't trust her and also this girl while
cute and adorable isn't really that
innocent as she seems no one in the
Tomodachi game has made it here without
stepping on a few toes and breaking a
few hearts and she doesn't seem any
different with the give up grenade in
our possession we can tell her to hide
wherever we please and know that the
girl couldn't give up if she wanted to
then if we had to estimate that would
give us about three days to find the
other Hider before this girl goes crazy
or dies from lack of food and water but
her sacrifice will be for our game thank
you so it's about as Fair as you can get
in anime anyways yuichi decides that
tenji is going to hide in a small cave
onto the Cliffside making sure that the
new girl doesn't know his location three
days pass inuichi still hasn't returned
to give him food and water that night
yuichi tells the opposing team that he
wants to switch sides the enemy team
decides to let him in and call their
Captain to ask for permission to let him
really join them he tells them to not
let yuichi join their side instead he
asks the girl to change teams but yuichi
decides to forget about changing teams
knowing that he has a plan up his sleeve
the morning after half of the enemy team
left to give their Captain food yuichi
has a heart-to-heart conversation with a
spiky-haired blondie here trying to make
him suspicious of his buddies this
brown-haired kid interrupts to switch
places and Blondie walks over to Maria's
bedside to find out that she's
disappeared walking deeper into the
forest he finds the girl cleaning
herself up in her underwear and he
freaks out and runs back to tell his
buddy what just happened but that's when
yuichi steals the food rations and runs
off the enemy team chases after them and
he decides to do something crazy yuichi
pushes the new girl off of the Cliff's
side and she starts to fall to her death
but Blondie jumps in in the nick of time
to save her from dying yuichi then
arrives at the cave and rushes in to
save Angie from Near Death he explains
that he was analyzing the team for the
last few days and pushed Maria off the
cliff like a madman to use her as a
distraction The Seekers meet back up at
the food ration location where tensions
are high as hell uh eggs the enemy team
on causing the blonde guy to become
violent but that's when he realizes that
he can use blonde guy's crush on Maria
as a path to Victory suddenly the blonde
guy requests to move to yuichi's team
and is instantly approved that night the
new team member is tied up and Maria
here pretends to fear for his safety she
tries to find out more about the enemy
Captain but he reveals that his old
Captain didn't even tell them where he
was hiding shocked yuichi questions how
he never found out the captain's
location but then bowl cut here calls
him and reveals to yuichi that he was
the captain all along and tells him that
the blonde kid is a liability and
resorts to violence easily okay this
might not have been the best idea the
blonde kid is a hot-headed individual
and that means we can easily lose this
game by way of disqualification however
we can use this to our advantage and
figure out a way to win through the same
method using mental mind games has been
The Key to Our Success throughout all
three games and this one isn't any
different if I was yuichi I would tie
the kid up as soon as possible and
luckily the kid is firmly tied to this
tree I would start by gathering all the
personal information I can about his
ex-teamates and use that as a weapon
with this knowledge I could leak out
juicy details to the enemy team and try
to rile them up enough so that him and
his now opposing team get into a fight
because Remember Violence Against the
opposing team is strictly prohibited and
would instantly disqualify them if
they're stupid enough to get violent the
next day the enemy team shows up and
tells them to stay put orea tells them
that she's going for a toilet break and
runs into bowl cut kit he confronts her
about being planted by the game Masters
and demands that she betray yuichi by
giving her an offer that she cannot
refuse moments later she calls her
teammate to ask about tenji's hiding
spot suddenly yuichi spots her revealing
all their information to the enemy team
the bowl cut kid calls tenji and tells
him that yuichi is willing to let his
teammate die if it gives him the win
tenji screams out that he's lying and
the new captain reveals that he's right
above him manibu orders everyone to meet
up so he can announce the winner the
winner of the third and final game is
yuichi's group everyone is shocked and
the fake Captain admits that he pressed
the GIF a button before the game ended
yuichi came up with a genius plan he
called to the fake captain and
threatened to break his buddy's fingers
if he didn't give up with that the group
wins 2 million yen and the third game is
over however they're going to realize
that the Tomodachi game isn't over just
the boys decide to head straight to
school and find shiho entering the
classroom they see their old teammate
utori who tells them that the others
have disappeared she tells them that the
confessions from the second game were
broadcasted to the entire world and
chibe's father is in big trouble that
night the boys discuss what to do about
the current situation a mystery number
calls tenjin asks if his genius buddy is
with him the caller displays a photo of
you Tori tied up and tells them to meet
him in an abandoned warehouse or she'll
be seriously hurt okay no no no no no I
say skip that the best way of going
about this situation would be to leave
her butt with the sharks everyone in our
group seems to be a damn evil piece of
crap and this game is causing us more
trouble than we could have ever imagined
if I were the boys I'd call it a day
we've just been through three grueling
games together and had the hardest route
through the game compared to others it's
not our job to be the local police and
we should probably just go back to
school and hit the books like a normal
Japanese teenager that being said though
nearly a hundred children have been
kidnapped from 2021 to 2022 in the
country of Japan these crimes have been
increasing at a constant rate and the
police should be aware that a high
school student has gone completely
missing we should agree to come to
wherever this mysterious person wants to
take us once he gives us the location
we'll then call the police and tell them
where they're at it's a win-win
situation we don't have to get our hands
dirty and potentially risk our lives for
the slim chance of success and the
police won't be knocking on our doors if
we end up getting a Tory here killed
yuichi arrives at the destined location
only to be confronted by a group of
thugs this white-haired man kuroki
introduces himself as the emcee of the
next game the weak will game yuichi here
isn't allowed to talk or move and will
be forced to go through three rounds of
pain if he can pass them all he'll let
him and yutori go free however yotori
here can volunteer to take some of the
damage as well if she's feeling oh so
Noble koroka introduces this massive
Beefcake bodybuilder friend and gives
the option for yuichi to take three hits
or for yatori to take one she doesn't
say anything entire time and the
punishment automatically goes to yuichi
the MC introduces the next round called
fingernail removal and gives them two
options once again your Torre can have
one fingernail removed or yuichi can
have three ripped off and yuichi steps
up to the challenge and is given the
brutal punishment the third and final
round is the most sadistic one yet
yatori has the option of exotically
stripping down and being agreed by all
the guys or yuichi can have his hand
gouged out instead he decides to take
the punishment and has his hand brutally
disfigured by the MC jitori begs for
forgiveness and apologizes for not
taking any of the pain and patches up
his hand he forgives the girl and turns
over to the MC offering to play one
final game rock paper scissors if kuroki
wins yuichi will hand over 10 million
yen in cash but if he loses yuichi gets
to cut off a certain number of fingers
depending on which hand he threw he
convinces kuroki's Lackey to agree with
his offer by handing out 1 million to
each person if their leader wins not
only that with his wrapped up hand Ichi
can only throw rock or paper on the
count of three they throw down and the
MC realizes he made a big mistake yuichi
throws scissors with his other hand and
wins the game okay that was a total
clutch move and technically means that
he wins him the game we're not exactly
dealing with morally sound people here
these guys are thugs through and through
meaning they're ready to do whatever it
takes to get at us they've already
kidnapped our friend here so there's
likely no way they won't cross the line
when it comes to harming us however the
key word is us in a life or death
situation there's only one person I care
about and that's myself while we might
have convinced his lackeys to egg their
leader on and play my game there's no
telling what the reaction could be once
I win through semi alleged cheated just
because it makes sense in a technical
way doesn't mean these thugs won't just
technically beat my ass for trying to
pull a fast one there's nothing stopping
us from leaving this dirty warehouse and
our ragtag group of friends behind we
will be living stress-free for the rest
of our lives and get out of the [ __ ]
show with a few little bumps and bruises
Furious kuroki tells his thugs to grab
the kid and teach him a lesson that's
when the Tomodachi game management
bursts inside and restrains all of the
thugs the managers tell karoki that he's
in trouble for impersonating manabu but
yuichi here isn't done with him yet he
tells the managers to lay off for a
second and says that he must collect his
prize and gives karaoke an option for
which fingers he wants to cut off
suddenly he passes out on the spot and
the managers take him away for emergency
medical Aid they're not gonna let their
best Prada die this easily the new girl
Maria offers the remaining participants
a brand new game to save shebe however
if they lose they'll be given 500
million yen in debt yuichu wakes up to
encourage the others to keep on going
all the while he chills in the hospital
Scott freeze and if you don't want Scott
to chill out of your hospital then like
comment let us know what you liked and
of course didn't like and don't forget
to check out the how to be playlist down
below